and the dank and I feel like we're on
like a like a like a morning radio show
coming at you from the dark and Thursday
yes but now we have to come up with
silly names yeah cuz it's always like
I'm it's like welcome to Saturday
morning radio with cibo in the skin like
yeah you know the woody show God all
that is those those are them names dem
dem nom nom ins yeah no um Bob no so the
dance party room was Brazil Brazil uh Oh
J Richard Kelly Oh Tess wish I me yes he
goes by J Richard Kelly which always
annoys the [ __ ] out of Charlie when I
Colin J Richard Kelly because it's what
he credits himself as rich richer Kelly
yet I thought he was just really Kelly
for a while I wanted to become J Richard
Kelly's you're killing wouldn't we
totally look this up on its google time
come with me and we'll see i landed your
information hey Wibbly Wankel Xin the
chocolate facto factum yeah the
chocolate decadence fact odor is hello
Devon so much uh J Richard Kelly Richard
Kelly mr. Kelly it does get very surreal
and alone and you do like just the
sudden like being jolted from room to
room and like milieu de mil you is like
oh it's an interesting experience I've
never gone through anything like alone
before the scavenger hunt was very
different from just going through her
natural haunt well that was like that
was yeah that was it was still like they
like puzzles than they like you know
surreal and then and you know the sort
of cerebral stuff but then yeah the the
scavenger hunt was a free event you know
you had to figure out and unlock some
things to get access to it but you know
as a free event and it was to wrap the
story this is more this is getting
closer to you know their show and I I
feel like I could be wrong but I feel
like the October show is the center
peace like you the resort shin is going
to be the big PS de resistance yeah like
where the most you know time and
resources go you know they'll probably
have the biggest space for that and I
wonder if they're going to be different
in different venues and sow sow
dissension yeah this will just feel like
they'd have yeah this was in the theater
and so the theater has starts with like
a play and yeah what and I like has the
idea of like you know this is we're in
the theater this is a space where an
ideas are dispensed to a public and
you're gonna watch a bit from a play
about an idea getting diffuse through
the public and now you're going to be
shown through and you're going to like
go into and out of these groups we're
different kind of like commands and
directives or spread through you in
different ways yeah to me like the dance
party room was kind of like the the kind
of climax of diffusion you know so it's
like the dance party room and for me
it's like I'm walking down this hallway
I don't know which way to go there's one
door ahead of you that lights furniture
and then there's another door next to me
that lights pouring through I'm thinking
I'm gonna check out the door next to me
first even though I'm pretty sure the
door headed means why should be going
for and before I could even get into the
door next to me a guy bursts out of it
yeah yeahs me and throws me into the
door at the end of the hall and so I
person did this hazy foggy room where
all these things that I assume our
people are kind of dancing in the circle
around this big table where all these
people are dancing on top of it and just
hazy and foggy and there's a strobe
light going and there's um there's like
you know noise rock and stuff going on I
can't make out details in the room I
can't tell what's going on and so I end
up falling into the circle with everyone
dancing around this table and my hands
are up because I'm still like the [ __ ]
going on yeah like gardening myself and
then I look ahead of me and I see
there's a girl dancing on top of the
table that's in like this kind of like
60 s kind of mod black Go Go jumpsuit
ething the only thing I could describe
is like it reminds me of like the that
60s mini series the prisoner
it looks like something like someone in
bed that show the prisoner would wear
and she was like playing with everyone's
hair as they pass by and so it's like it
was just this really weird person at
some point someone on the table why I
guess was just like another guest
another like ticket buyer and not an
actor like guides me to get up on the
table and so I have to hunch because my
my head's hitting the ceiling when I'm
on this table was the ceiling solo to
toe I'm truthful beat the five-foot-four
like every other celebrity I know right
just five before it with a big head is a
big head and so I'm standing on this
table kind of awkwardly and then it's
like the the prison or girl is like
playing with everybody and and like at
some point she's like putting her hand
up and I don't know what to do with that
so I just kind of put my hand up against
hers and then as as I'm we're just kinda
like pressing our hands to go she's
dating up in my face and making these
different faces with the strobe lights
and they're all like some of them are
smiling and then some of them looks
Stern and then one looks almost like
this kinda like kind of like almost
erotic like a lip bite thing it was all
like very kind of unnerving well as
that's that's one of the things they do
such a [ __ ] I was playing with is
giving you a prompt of some kind of just
seeing what you do with that you know
it's like whether it's like a prolonged
eye contact or whether it's you know
something maybe silly or playful you
know it's like that dance room I feel
like was kind of designed just to see
what people do because they're like
you're in this mode that's serious is
the wrong word but it's kind of seeing
so like it's not you're not in the mood
to like you know moving and grooving and
you know be silly but it's like then
asking you to kind of flip around and
demanding good of you yeah it's like and
now here's a dance party you can do what
you dance can you can like you know what
is I gonna do like like will you dance
I'm like I've been like yanked around of
thrown through hallways and like treated
very bizarrely and now you're just
asking me to join this party yeah it's
like I don't feel like loose and silly
enough to dance
the same time I kind of feel like I
oughta just engage and move wouldn't
through the music so you know it's an
interesting exploration of just your own
reaction to things there and then and
then after you kind of go around the
table and up and it's like at some point
it's like the people that were on top of
the table ended up like clearing off and
it was it was just kind of like me and
the Prisoner girl and she like turned
her attention to other people so I got
off the table and went around the circle
with everyone else a few times of them
got pulled out and then thrown into the
rest of the the maze but it was like I
don't know the dance party room kind of
if anything else in that whole scenario
the dance party room had the biggest
effect on me because it was just like
this awkward and the other way I can
describe is like forced intimacy but it
wasn't forced as in like it was fake but
was like I was being aggressively
intimated with yeah it's like I did not
have a choice someone was going to like
the rust intimacy upon me well yeah
because everyone you it feels like all
the regular people you bump into are all
genuine in whatever their reactions
might be and all the actors who engage
with you they're all giving you a thing
it's like it doesn't yeah it's like that
forest intimacy if like it doesn't feel
fake because they're giving you
something very specific that they you
know our understandingly throwing at you
and it's sort of like oh I should do
something yeah but what you know so it's
you know again they're really good at
summing themselves up you know they're
these like emotional experiments and
they're really cool they're p cool
Michael and then pick an AP and then at
some point they very masterfully direct
you back into the theater where you like
first past the room mm-hmm and I got to
see the end of the scene yeah oh no we
both said yeah yeah we got to see the
end it seemed well I got to see the end
of the scene again so yeah I never saw
the end scene first time so it was like
whoa it was like kind of a cool full
circle you know getting fed through the
beginning and then coming back and being
like wait a minute this is that this is
about where I left yeah you know great
last time on last time on our
Miller's the crucible yeah it feels like
you know it feels like the first chapter
or something but it it's definitely
caught Philly nuts I would turn out for
anything you guys do so this is always
interesting and me they're always
topping it and it's from an aesthetic
standpoint they're always doing stuff is
very cool because it's like this you
know the past there was almost kind like
this we're like a tease new agey thing
and for the first time like they kind of
went for the the first series like their
their aesthetic was very monochromatic
and this time because it's like all
Rainbow theme there's all this color and
like you know some of the promo art and
promo audio stuff has this kind of like
analog synth sound to it and it all
feels like have you ever seen beyond the
Black Rain which is like this
whacked-out weird kind of like 80s
throwback your face trivial trippy up to
subpoena sort of metaphorical yes
strangeness yeah it's it's balls out
weird and it's like this weird
intersection of an art movie in a
grindhouse movie yanks and so if you've
ever seen beyond the black rainbow going
through a loan is like going through
kind of an intimate personal real-life
version of beyond the black rainbow and
it's funny you should say that because
when we came out of the the enola show
the October show you know it's like you
know you get back in the car and you're
still feeling it and that was that was
the only thing that made sense to just
sort of put on the radio for background
music was to be on the black rainbow
soundtrack and and the people in the car
with me even commented they're like do
you have the music already and I was
like oh no this is from this is beyond
the black rainbow but it but right like
it yeah actually the mood you know Matt
Stone yeah um yeah and so I got to the
scavenger hunt there was like music that
was in different parts of the scam gun
so they released the like the mixtape
that was the sonic background for that
after the fact so I would be so down to
get them get the music for especially
the dance party room because it was like
it was actually really cool oh yeah it
was discordant and creepy and noisy
but oddly really really listenable yeah
perfect for having an excuse I don't
know what it is with us like the dance
party room in like with the prisoner
girl like that felt very weird that that
got under my skin no oh yeah I don't see
I always there's always there's
something cool about it each and every I
always find that there's something
clever than something I appreciate about
each and everything but I think my
favorite stuff is always when it's just
me you and whatever and I remember in
the first sequence of hallways that was
a really sort of unsettling thing as I
was walking to the dark and there was a
I swear there was a girl there but like
your eyes are adjusting just the point
where I'm like that's a person yeah I'm
walking by her I don't know what she's
gonna do and I'm it's just dark enough
that I'm not a hundred percent sure I
think I have the experience one time
where it's like I could see someone in
the dark and I just sort of looked at
whether their shape was passed by it and
they grabbed me as soon as I have my
back to them and that was just like yeah
jarring one that was that when I first
got to that costume room like the guy
who was pulling people in was and just
but and probably pushed somebody in
there so the door was open I could see
his his silhouette sort of illuminated
by the light leaking out of the door and
that was all I saw at the end of the
hall as soon as I got into the hall so
then when he closed the door he was gone
and my eyes had to adjust again it was
like great now I have to walk towards
vaguely where I know there's something
but maybe there he moved like I don't
know you know used its those great
little little fake outs and playing with
your your eyes using your head brain and
your mind and your head too yeah so I'm
just wondering it's like if the theme
for diffusion was I don't know it's like
I guess I'm just thinking you know the
way in which the creators of this i
found a podcast were they were talking
about like what they try and do with you
alone hon they just kind of like want to
give you
they want to give everyone like a good
background it's like they want to create
like a good kind of bowl for everybody
to put whatever they're going to put
into it into it so but it feels like
going through diffusion there was like
something I was supposed to get out of
it but I just don't know how to I just
don't know how to articulate it or even
what sense to make of it I feel like
that's that is I feel like whatever
since you make of this sort of person of
everybody I feel like that's kind of the
point is to this to never be quite
definite you know just to be as fleeting
and and you know mystical as the
traveling of life yeah and diffusion did
feel I mean after after was over it felt
short but was like we were in there for
looking good our almost yeah probably i
mean i know nomar we went in and came
back out like it feels when I I remember
checking our hand or checking my watch
when we got out and it's like okay
judging by when we got out when we were
supposed to go in supposed to have gone
in like we had to have been in there
[ __ ] good hour I think so but I mean
it felt short at the end of it mm-hmm
well I mean certain you know they've
clearly put a lot of time and thought
into how they can stagger people and how
they can handle oh yeah and how they can
handle you know the fact that different
people take different you know time you
don't realize it but they're only there
apparently the security cameras all
through the maze and the guys running it
are queuing every single active as it
goes along right letting people know
where you know where I guess the next
person is coming from or whatever and
also I imagine a certain point where
they get to all of you then certain
actors would relocate or whatever you
know it's it's all very well done so I'm
very well put together yeah it's kind of
a like a Rube Goldberg machine of
surreal spookiness so it's like I wanted
I'm really down to see you like what the
the concurrent or what the following
episodes are like and how those those
indices kind of like expand or develop
what
that up now mmm chapter 2 think I get on
that index 2 which is refraction action
yeah so apparently refraction is going
to be taking place at scare away scared
us and he leans into August scare louisa
may scare loose scare lalalala I want to
know like what other what other towns
have like a big Halloween Haunt thing
because it's like for whatever reason L
easy so it's become like a big thing in
that way yeah well I mean and I mean
across the country to is like you know I
mean hot in general like blackouts huge
and black polka New York yeah home
haunts are a big thing you know every
every region has theme perks that do
honson and home handsome you know their
own you know Vegas has frequent brothers
stuff like that there are all kinds of
ways to test your might so yeah it's
it's like halloween has gotten a lot
bigger than lately and haunt has gotten
a lot bigger too you know and that's I'm
happy for that spooky industrial complex
it's nice since I mean like I guess
everything should be in its right place
but it's nice you know when at least if
Christmas is gonna come out in October
Halloween is you know they're starting
your Gummer Hetal stuff yet by the end
of the summer instead of like hey it's
the second week of October here's some
Halloween stuff all right it's the
second last week October and it's all
gone you know it's it's nice as a as a
fan of spooky to have you know some some
of that vigor and and whatnot put behind
Google hello xingu holes are as me but
my brain is the jiggery-pokery
I just um wasn't jiggery-pokery like
something like Antonin Scalia's was
going about Bruce yes it was about it
was with the health care it was under
health care who's either health care or
it was or it was the gay marriage ruling
but it's just like whatever's going down
in Scott is and and then Scalia is not
happy scotus skotos scotus always sounds
like some kind of supercomputer go we've
got really big on like federal acronyms
right now notice and scotus 02 since
CODIS and FLOTUS did you sound like my
superhero robots I'm like they sound
like um they sound like the weird inbred
brothers of like some Roman dynasty
scotus also sounds like scrotum yes but
skoda sounds like it would be like the
insectoid kind of enemy of he-man yeah
yeah they gon sing some kind of
villainous creature yeah ack reach some
kind of creature yeah man what was it
Lindsey he caught it oh [ __ ] what what
was the first [ __ ] boat digger in
pokkiri and there was like this is a
buttered toast or Sarah oh yeah i saw
the John Oliver segment yeah about
Anna's squeeze jiggery-pokery Antonin
Scalia sounds like an angry Chad yeah no
no no not a happy man gotta have not a
happy man Supreme Court Justice Antonin
Scalia yeah but hey I mean you know it's
a it's a good it's a good week for you
know but never want things I guess if
you're listening to this and in school
yet I hope your I hope I hope things
work out for you uh and if you listen to
this um you know props on the old timey
vocab see I really appreciate them
you're here sticking to your guns and
using
yeah the antiquated parlance you know so
yeah super spooky super spooky I don't I
mean would you be comfortable dishing
like what do these are anyone i don't
use dishes only got that oh well
fantastic I don't know is there anything
like deep and dark and meaningful
personal that you think got out of your
because you've gone alone way more off
than me so is there anything deep and
dark and personal you've gotten out of
it um man it's always a moment it's like
you know it's it's always interesting
interacting with its like you learn
about you and it's like I the more I do
these the less I'm trying to be cautious
and guarded and the more I'm trying to
sort of let go and be a part of the
thing and just sort of really kind of
fearless Lee engaged with it I mean I I
like you know you get that rush off the
intensity of you know the spookier parts
but when you're interacting with actors
and stuff like that you know it's like
those parts really hit me in a very
specific way and I think the dance party
with the girl on the tables like that
the moment that I actually got that
because the rest of it it was like I was
getting Stern instructions or who's just
getting thrown around those like that
that thing with the girl on the table is
like the first time that opportunity to
kind of like what this hit me happen
well that was I had like that that was
the first actual like the moment you
know cuz like there was the first girl i
met the hallway like it was pretty quick
like she was freaky and then she threw
me in the next room but that whole thing
with the markers and oh yeah that girl
like talking at you and stuff like that
kind of throwing you around was like it
got my attention the first thing the
worst thing that happened after you went
under the table went into the hallway
behind the theater stage was girl grabs
you throws you in the room sits you in a
chair and gives you this kind of like
overly poetic new age ish feel about how
light works and what I wanted it she got
in my face and was like did you know
that when you look at color or
when you see anything you're not seeing
what you're seeing is your perception of
it you are seeing the very act of your
own perceiving just basically now it's
like because you know site doesn't exist
until it's kind of interpreted by your
brain so there's that kind of like
disconnecting it between reality and
perceptions and when she's giving me the
spiel she is turning my face to look at
myself in a mirror that was oddly
effective yeah and then she grabs these
like bundles of of kind of like skin
body crayons and just draws the and
they're bundled together so she puts
like six or seven line just down both of
your forearms yeah and then she's a
biotic rainbow colors yeah and then she
says that color color is the pain of
light which sounds ridiculous that the
moment was I was getting in your face
and is throwing you into a chair it hits
you yeah works like it's it's a visceral
moment you know it's like it grabs your
attention cuz it's your attention like
and I feel like that line because it is
such like a Whammer line that is
something that's going to kind of be
discussed in like the later indices as
they talk more about those are all based
off another step in the in depth
interaction between light and objects
yeah I'm really curious to see where
this goes because this didn't feel
introductory to me yeah and it did feel
and it did feel something chapter of a
shorter is like this felt like a shorter
experience then you know the body
experience did no but it fittingly so
it's it's the first you know it's the
first chapter so it was just intriguing
it was just so nice to be back in that
vein again you know because I like what
their voices so yeah it's like this was
interesting because it was different it
was like like you said it was that
constant back and forth between being on
your own and then with people and sort
of the ebb and flow of that you know
sort of coming together and breaking
apart and you know you we get to you
know you feel your your mind and your
body of those
you're very aware of space and air you
know and and that's the stuff i kind of
love about this you know and i like i
like the interactive the sort of
one-on-one scenarios of each and that's
something I think will and I hope will
ramp up as the indices ramp up because
like this the one in October again was
like each room was a different like is
you and a situation or or an actor or
you know something and there are so many
is very personal that way so this one
was kind of a back and forth between
those which is cool in a different way
so you know I I like the personal stuff
you know and that's those are the sort
of things that push me the most sort of
challenging challenge jingles although
thinking of getting in that room saw the
people and it's that that weird
push-pull of its kind of wacky just
putting clothes on people and tying
stuff on each other but I think that's
the point is it supposed to kind of
strip you to this very sort of fluid
place of just like you know kind of
being a puppet yeah you submit yourself
to what's going on you know to what
they're you know you can still move and
do things that's that's the
encouragement but you know it's like in
opening yourself up to doing that you
know in taking more control the
situation you're almost submitting to
the greater you know scheming no you
know because like if you make the choice
to dance in the dance party room it's
like you are you're doing what the space
is demanding of you yeah you know it
makes you feel room and it makes you you
know perceive a harder there's less
tunnel vision yeah it's funny it's like
the more restricting the revision is the
less you have tunnel vision it turn a
tunnel vision but he was overcome a
mobile but first he bought that crack
back might be yo yo oh my god that jay-z
okay I'm sorry correct I gresham well
that's that was a cool thing um that was
a cool thing about this one in
particular was all the stuff that like
okay I got decent it at sort of just
kind of vibing with what was going on so
especially in the visual like you know
when they're when they're projecting all
that stuff across the sheet that's on
your face like I did kind of start to
just sort of haze and trip a little bit
on that you know or in the the dressing
room with the strobe it's like I did
just sort of start to you know you
remember it a more figurative way yeah
you know it's you start to trance out
you start to feel that desert not dizzy
but they're pummeling her fog into every
room of it it felt like they were
pumping falls in the theater when you're
watching the scene on the same day they
were definitely pumping fog into the
into the dance party room well that
gives it an otherworldly quality yeah
and it's like once you start pumping fog
into 11 rural invariably just starts
spreading all over the place so it's
like there was something very dreamlike
about being there yes we're Slyke and
then you add a strobe on to it so it's
like you're your inner you're being
forced with way too much information and
then way too little information to just
understand your surroundings yeah when I
feel like the sort of trappings like
that's the world that all these take
place and it's like it's it's
otherworldly but not it's like it's not
quite it's like it's it's it's the world
you live in but like a different like a
sub thread of that war i'm going to i'm
going to go off my rocker for a second
year but i'm going to say it's basically
it's the experience that we're always
trying to run away from the fact that
you know we go about our daily lives
trying to like exert some idea of
understanding and control and go about
thinking the to a greater extent them is
true we know what we're doing and we
know what's going on but in reality just
like the very nature of like taking
stock of the fact that we are alive is
like we're kind of thrown into the world
out of
our control we don't have veal you know
apprehension of what's going on we're
full of haziness and confusion and
indistinct ideas of just anything going
on in our lives and so I was like going
through this home is basically just
taking that making a manifest and making
it real yeah yeah that's like it's it's
you as a part of a as like a cog in a
bigger sort of electronics loud of life
yeah I guess you wouldn't be a cognitive
sort of being pulled and pulled and
pushed by outside forces and sort of
cast into situations that you know they
know but you don't you you know and
that's kind of yeah how are you living
in the experience of thrown pneus it's
like whatever the outside forces knows
the construct better than you do and is
going to put you there like it's gonna
guide you there whether you like it or
not we're we've got the safeway yeah
there's there is a plan you don't know
the plan the plan is something you can't
even wrap your head around just
understanding the day-to-day events that
are going a hundred just go with the
place yeah just go with the plan the
plan will make no sense will give you
will give you the plan scope yeah just
so damn yeah I'm happy that these dudes
do what they do it was pretty dang it
was very dim dang the day guess dang his
help so I'm excited I can't wait for
round two I gotta get on that ya gotta
find my arrangements yeah you know track
down some tix ya gotta get refracted ya
Gong you ever fragment been diffused we
ought to be refracted we have to get lit
up ya gotta gotta get rainbow the [ __ ]
out for ye I don't know there was
something weird it was like like the
scavenger hunt for instance kind of
ended up with this this weird kind of
like like at the very end of the
scavenger hunt to get pulled in this
room and there's like the actors going
through this bizarre noisy thing that's
it's almost like
and with the space and with the words
that were being spoken in this in this
kind of episode at the very end of the
scavenger hunt it was almost like
Christianity as viewed through the cult
in the first season of True detective
huh so it was like very like weird and
like incomprehensible but like still
fervent and like fanatical and the guy
kept on like shouting about God in yeah
this was apparently you know at the end
of getting bounced back and forth
between Enola and this rival
organization this guy's referring to
himself as as someone who is from the
enola foundation so it's like I'm
wondering is there going to be a
culmination at the end of end of the
whole rainbow thing I am colors hi I'm
covers a man like a cow where's this go
way because the scavenger hunt was cool
but it's like it felt like they were
sweeping a story with the the two
warring factions in the two warring
entities enola and the Society for
propagation of functional information or
spiffy for shorts if he kind of emerged
out of nowhere in the middle of the
scavenger hunt and just sort of start
with hijacking your instructions huh so
it was I'm just interests like how is
that gonna like how is that gonna pan
out in um you know in the in the index
sees thing indices I don't know I mean I
feel like I'm a Coursera no Mon Sep this
time is more abstract it's like it was
always there's not a there's not a
backstory of in enola foundation there's
just this theme of hey colors yeah
there's no impose I you know
organization or or you know they've made
a website for you know a foundation on
the last one like yours is highly
interactive that way this one it seems
like it's more much more elemental and
conceptual you know because you know
that makes sense for the enola storyline
because it's under the conceit of this
is a foundation that can help you you
know so it's it has more human
components that I feel like this dogs
this has you started more aesthetic and
abstract components yeah this may be
very crackpot but even the people in
this iteration almost feel like or at
least my mind sort of reinterpreted them
as not so much people but just you know
swarms of light like you know if light
is the idea you know if light is at the
core then you know anything you can see
is all you don't like bouncing off and
stuff so perhaps this is just light bent
and now sending you a message and then
dissipating again when it sends you into
the next room so it's like cause like
you know in them that's sort of in the
scavenger client and in end in the haunt
from what I die here like last year's
haunt and scavenger hunt there were
individual specific characters that have
like a specific kind of like look in
time element to them like during the
scavenger hunt for instance there was
this girl who was like a classical clown
but like it was just like mining and
being widely this kind of interesting
weird way there were these kind of
official old older guys that were like
the enola reps or the leaders of an
o-line in this Gavin drive yeah that was
it was a lot more fake in the in this
it's like the the characters you
interact with like I can only get glom
onto the prisoner girl because she was
the one who just had anything distinct
phone about her besides the guy in the
red jacket in the wardrobe room and the
end actors doing the crucible seen
everyone else that grabs you and is
forcing you into different rooms even
the girl that gives you the spiel about
colors the pain of light they're all
just people in black garb that are just
they feel very like arbitrary and like
anonymous and kind of faceless in that
way yeah exactly so it's like you know
in the suspension of just really valence
feel like they wouldn't be people there
just you know yeah like manipulating
itself to communicate a thing to you
before sending you along your way or
just imagining what it would be like if
instead of instead of you know people in
black are but they were looking full
blackout like morphsuit garb hmm and I
think it's it's cool though if they take
a sore
you know yeah I'm not about just to give
it that extra otherworldly kind of like
inter mile to it well they did they did
things like that in certain parts of the
enola one because the enola one was sort
of sort of dipped in and out of you
dipped in and out of what was close to
reality it's like you started with this
breathing exercise and a woman you know
who's clearly with the foundation you
know they had people up front these
white suits and stuff like that like you
started in a world close to our own and
then as you got further in you know some
of the early some of the more
preliminary rooms run cultish but still
like human and then as you got further
and the rooms got more surreal and more
strange and you know the way like
instead of people you know there would
be these these creature things you know
people would soothe it was like they
were they would be in suits there would
be you know changed so as not to look
human anymore not to look entirely like
people so they did and they do and we
might see more of that as time goes on
you never know um but yeah that was sort
of like the original a sort of descended
further into strange surreal you know
and then when you saw another just
person again it was sort of weird you
know and the enola like there were less
defined characters and that one has like
the older deal their general is we've
seen now a couple times he was in the
hunt but he was in you know you sort of
sat down with him and at dinner table
and you talked about autopsy like it it
wasn't it wasn't as a sort of obviously
tied into a plotline as much as it was
like here's another sort of strange
situation that was there so links in a
sort of associative way I'm wrong room
just hearing about the same hand I'm
reminded of the dinner table scene from
Eraserhead yeah kinda just kind of
having that experience of just kind of
being that in that totally alienating
tie like dream world
where nothing's quite following the
rules are used to social interactions
following and they're they're pretty
good to Adam especially in the October
hunt like the people moving you from
place to place we're usually coming from
a place you wouldn't be looking so you
know I mean you can see them if you you
know looked around are you caught one
but you know usually they would come up
from somewhere else and move you along
and so you never really got a great
sense for who any of them were just that
they were moving you so that kind of
contributed to the immersive mrs. like
it's if you suspend your disbelief
enough it's just a force that kind of
moves you from place to place yeah you
know and they all kind of our in
character so to speak you know they all
sort of hold up the aesthetic and they
do I mean there's something really
brilliant or just like you know even in
diffusion in this last ones like you
know you you have those moments of not
knowing which way you're going well like
at times they burst you out of the
theater building entirely on the street
before you know what you're getting from
back into it through a different door
yeah they're gonna find what space
they're gonna using all full up it's
like you're just kinda like walking
forward whichever way you think you're
supposed to walk forward and then
specifically in your blind spot someone
is is graphing you and put you where
you're supposed to be next yeah graphic
if I may be allowed to UM is interesting
as far as like the way was different
people react to it if I mean if I may be
allowed to speak for air at the first
and she told me something interesting at
the end of it word it was like I felt
calmer in there than I do normally ya
know Sully why she was just able to let
herself reach that moment of of cutting
loose and going with it yeah no I mean
that's that's how I felt too i mean like
you know your cuz you're you're in your
body so much you're just here you know
there's i feel like when i want a min
when I all the times I've done these
when I'm in there not really focused on
anything outside it's just I'm here and
I mean
gave you and that was the thing again
back in October was like we got to the
lounge afterwards because because i
think the octo was like the picture too
because like this pastime you know doe
sec he's like sponsored their their
lounge you know and then the new Angeles
was fitting but you know it was still
you know a nice place to kind of sit
right so stay alone my friends stay
alone my friend but um you know it's
like it was that thing of like you know
parts of the show like I said we're
creeping on settling parts were scary
but other parts were sort of touching
and soothing and beautiful and when we
got to the lounge there were so relaxed
and is so like you know is the most
peaceful is relaxed and happy I had felt
you know all month you know in a long
time even just sitting in the lounge
afterwards and it is kind of like it you
know it's it's Anika thorac experience
and it's you know an experience that
makes you you go to places that you can
you don't really access on a day-to-day
basis that's making me wonder because
like you know the i guess the
conventional wisdom is that um you know
people people keep on saying like the
whole reason the halloween haunt and the
desire to keep on going more extreme and
more intense with it it's coming from
you know it's like people don't come
into like really having a sense of
danger anymore mmm not a not at a
personal really really punchy level that
you know that used to be so such a huge
fixture just life in general we're also
comfortable they're also secure so it's
like we kind of need to get back in
touch with that feeling of you know I'm
gonna die well yeah it's like it you
know horror in general and you know and
this this sort of this isn't just horror
but it's like you know honson and horror
movies and stuff like that they're all
sort of at least partially a way to you
know challenge the more upsetting and
more uncomfortable parts of life in a
controlled environment and it's like
you know I think since haunts are such a
common thing now it's like these more
and more of these are popping up because
you know the rush the rush goes away a
little bit when your nose like everybody
knows what the carnival hunt environment
is like now and so it's harder to get
you know to learn and to get you know
scared um and so these are you know it's
like the bigger test it's why I like is
the difference between watching it's
like a movie that's actually scary is
harder to come by now than you might
think or at least you know if you're if
you watch a decent amount or because
it's like you know there's a whole
notion of what people are getting such
fatigue / jump scared it's like there
are no there are no real avenues for
like most horror movies are just they
just go off of having like the startled
we actually can't really get under your
skin and that personal feeling of dread
anymore yeah that's um that I loved
about the babadook so much it was so
personal yeah exactly a spark or movies
are concerned and I mean that's you know
it's a safe environment to sort of test
your limits and you know it's like not
that these are in any way same but it
was like you know sing gonna watch the
human centipede 2 I was really nervous I
didn't know what I would get and I
didn't know what that and that was a
strange difficult experience and like
that's what a horror movie can do is you
can challenge those those things and
that's what haunts are now doing was you
can challenge your limits and in a you
can make an agreement and then sort of
see what's in there you know what you
can see what you're made of at some of
the more you know aggressive ones or
with something like a loan you can sort
of see what's what's lurking in your
mind you know and what your eyes are
gonna do in the dark mmm I don't think
that alone is like you know if answer it
like you're more typical horror haunt is
there to like give you the feeling away
you know a simulated kind of physical
danger and everything and they get your
blood pumping in that way you know then
I guess alone is and you know it's like
the no more horror class will haunt is
there to kind of like replace the vibe
that we're not coming
mortal danger anymore maybe alone in the
ecology is there because we're kind of
living sort of emotionally sedate lives
mm-hmm you know we're not really coming
into contact with really kind of the
depths of you know feeling isolated or
lost or confused you know we're we're
told that there's so much connectivity
in the world and it's just kind of like
you know then at the same time you get
people's you know we have seemingly so
much more openness about people feeling
like severe depression or severe anxiety
out there and in the world I guess kind
of alone and what it does for people is
kind of get us back in touch with just
kind of like it says how fragile our
emotional and our psychological states
are wait cuz i said you know the world
now is an overly encouraging of people
getting in touch with emotion and and
sort of exploring it you know you can a
lot of people you know for whatever
reason don't seem to I mean I'm sure
everybody does when they're alone to a
degree you know just on their own but
you know it's like people don't explore
and it's easy to sort of not be plugged
into the world around especially when
you can carry a million distraction with
you and like everything is geared now
again that's what I what I partly what I
appreciate it so much about inside that
was like nowadays we're sort of told
that you know it's like mineral you
should be happy like you don't ever want
it like being sad as bad like you know
you should be happy you know blah blah
blah should be happy and active all the
time because everybody's happy and
active all the time and this is a cool
way of exploring some of the other
things and just testing them out you
know in an environment as a zoo in that
way creative and so it's it's personal
but it's not just mired in your own
details it's like here's here's
something we're sort of doing together
but I'm doing on my own can you imagine
like if alone was an entire theme park
that would be very straight I don't be
[ __ ] rad are you talking right i
don't know how work but yeah and i don't
know how they would like to have enough
of a i don't know how they would have
enough of like a repeat cuz thing is
like you know you can never really get
totally decent
ties to a roller coaster dropped our I
feel like after a while you get
desensitized to you know the the tools
that are being used to simulate certain
or get certain emotional reactions out
of you so they don't have to have things
kind of constantly rotating constantly
shifting and changing oh and that's why
these are special because they you know
you can go up a few times but they'll
only be a bottle a specific amount of
times in a year you know now they're
they're slightly more now but even each
time is changing theoretically if you go
once each cycle I want to go to I want
to go to a lone land and I imagine the
lone land has like a little simulated
village that's basically just like
Silent Hill yeah because it's empty and
foggy and things that you don't trust
are everywhere what's very into the one
October special is very silent hilly and
the sense that like you know some things
were people and other things like I
don't quite know what this thing is
that's walking past me and my touch me
at any moment you know and that's that's
the cool thing I think it's like they've
gotten very clever because it's not a
traditional haunt and they've sort of
used the haunt craze to create this
thing that is it at home enough
alongside other haunts but at the same
time is you know you sort of getting
people to explore like they said it's
like you're exploring emotion you're
exploring things like fear and
loneliness and isolation and the dark
you know things that you wouldn't
otherwise explore on your own
necessarily you're not encouraged to
explore just in your general life today
yeah you know and I think that's really
cool because you know it's like you you
might not realize it at the time or you
might realize it especially at the time
but you're sort of probing around the
dark matter of your brain you know so i
think that's that's awesome and there's
something dude they're trying to pick
for the last seen one be I wonder what
what the rush for tickets is going to be
like towards the end of this thing
because it's just like they sold out you
know up there up there Ford for index
passes and their and their diffusion
passes pretty quick well pretty quick it
seems like it's in a nice place where
it's like they did sell out
but it was like huh like in five minutes
they're gone you know it's like I you
know I was able to pretty you know I was
I didn't waste time but I was able to be
like oh yes I must go on the computer
well it wasn't like a little bit you
know like what are we gonna do um so I
feel like they're they're just cresting
to the point where pretty soon it'll be
hard to get tick yeah yeah god help us
one dot hafiz cuz I you know it's sort
of part of the charm is that it's you
know smallish and it's site-specific
it's sort of like what can we get all
right now it's work with that you know
hmm so-so I wonder if that's gonna I
wonder if that's gonna be thing go for
like more more venue means more like
different venue means more space means
like bigger capacity as the as the D
indices continue I would assume I mean
again you know just like judging by the
different things we've done you know the
one october they were able to have five
of us doing it at least at a time and
probably more depending on how
frequently they brought groups in this
clearly had to have like say where they
were pouring people into it at a pretty
decent pace they were they were able to
like get a decent crowd inside of the
dance room when you know get a decent
crowd inside of the the wardrobe room
when when they're needed a buildup of a
crowd yeah and it was like [ __ ]
brilliant pacing it's like when they
want you to be in the crowd you're in a
crowd when you they want you to be alone
you are oh whoa I'm seem like the pacing
was it was nice and staggered and
different for everybody you know cuz I
would notice like overlap like I'd be
like oh I didn't expect to see you you
went in so much earlier than I did you
know and now certain people finished
after me it's like everybody kind of got
shuffled and you know because we bumped
into each other in the wardrobe own good
Oh alone alone awesome alone alone I'll
pretty much show up for anything these
guys do I really like what they do you
know and then and that's it's my it's
more my pace yeah it's unique in its
meditative in what yeah it's like I'm
glad somebody has taken this formatting
and it's so soon you know and then sort
of done something like
yeah yeah getting cerebral with it you
know doing doing a thing do our thing
you know using it you know using it
meditatively creatively and giving us
you know for us you know arty types i
guess i'll go are you a patient stuff
inside no dude totes
it's a thing a thing yeah it's uh oh
it's true it's from terry irwin spooky
days I told you they were just dropping
things there is there I'm starting to
get a little skeeved was that they just
did a random dead drop in the middle of
good again I guess skeeved is the rock
war I'd said little creepy so crazy it's
very word oh where ya what is early
spewed is um I have been sponsoring a
few of their our episodes I'm trying to
I'm starting to wonder if they're
sponsoring or or or if we are a pond and
hit a bigger game in a bigger much
spookier game like some kind of like
like the game with Michael Douglas type
of thing exactly oh sorry let's see um
Walker you you are talk compa tours when
we do pay when it capitalized me yeah
cap wisely when we do pay for show rage
sincerely I arwyn spooky days that's
weird uh okay um what is a topic or the
competitor I would feel oh just always
always assume the big words have a
syllable Missy I feel like you just run
kid everything um a lot of frowny faces
on a frowny face a lot of frowny faces
and up and like a wingdings glyph of a
fighter but I well thanks to terry
spooky days for sponsoring the show yeah
thnkx terrorists pretend can we fix this
just by plugging
I I don't know I I don't know what this
means I have an idea what this maybe I
don't want to say what I think this
means because that's what the event
thing for this to me I think well you
know I mean they save seat relatively
good natured up until this point yeah
like they're they're mostly just
invested in people's ability to spooky
yeah so maybe they like that maybe then
maybe they could you know maybe draw
hair boom um creative executor of
Charlie's movie days maybe he kissed
exchange notes would be alone guys and
baby they could collabo that would be
awesome that would also be very straight
it'd be very strange every very strange
is a different boy yeah but I feel like
totally spooky days like there's a lot
of creative compatibility to work with
their amazing pros like a la ropa alone
didn't have a bathroom so I'm yeah yeah
and terrowin's days does their bathrooms
or open every days including Thursdays
through Sundays have linked to their
literature so you can go there to go to
the bathroom you one day the haunt
itself wherever Charlie two days is what
is closed and that's just great yeah I
mean that's just a public service that's
like hey I can't go spooky but I did
need to pee yes so and alone you could
be yeah I me there's a reward who time
they warned us about that there's some
tests to be on the paper oh yeah I don't
exactly know what that is so I will have
to we'll have to see what that is um I
just realize the paper too wet to get
him down to the lab yeah i'll give that
down too dank ass laboratory I mean
maybe it was just like maybe whose it
was just like a butcher paper yeah from
the meats on hook maybe hey which is all
slow the food court and so I get your
get your meat so if you get the chance
to go to a loan go to
loan but more importantly on go
determine spooky days no yeah great
every I mean both are great for their
own never tear when spooky days does and
we haven't found where they're located
but what they do as of yet but we will
you know hopefully I made you I think
you know and it's also I imagine this
it's not it's not pink haunts season you
know it doesn't seem like they have no
just the same kind of show in the same
kind of funds you know to put something
together like alone does yeah so
hopefully more tearing a spooky days
because I'm tournaments like October
interment spooky days is open every day
except thursdays through sundays um they
have to probably have like one set
location they can't just keep on
bouncing around rented been you
corrected venue like alone well yeah I
assume I'm you know I mean maybe there's
a kind of place that'll that would rent
out like a like just a vacant lot or
Slayer house yeah and just supposed to
happen where cornfield yeah you know so
maybe they can just shack up there for
like a month and a half and be open
every days except through its face to
Sundance so if you are in the LA area
and you want to get spooked you can't do
much better or worse than terylene to a
few days yeah spooky days and hey you
know what would be great is if Terry and
spooky days could marinate some of that
meat in Franca's tubs flank ass rub
that's right some of the most culinarily
mind-blowing I'm just making up words
now the copies is they didn't send us
coffee and I just said just winging it
yeah you know just imagine all the
different things you could do to your
meat on a hook you know you put spice
rub on it yeah yeah rub up rub up them
spices yeah get some get some that
caribbean jerk yeah you know aura and
while we're at it the elephant inflates
you in elephant inflates you uh boss my
balls enjoy your frostbite balls and all
these other day gasps memes
I shouldn't say enjoy of frostbite falls
it sounds like enjoyable Rita uh what's
enjoy your burrito as nerdist oh is that
a thing they do they tell people to
enjoy a burrito well yeah it's like it
came from or the episodes at were you
know they were they were counseling Matt
my run sort of in encouraging him to
embrace life you know sort of moderate
but embrace life you know it's like you
know as somehow it looped around that he
had this like you know great burrito and
it was just like no you should enjoy
your burrito and it was just sort of
like a just a general affirmation like
sort of a life-affirming thing and now
all the episodes and in enjoy your
burrito it's just a metaphor for like
you know I I watched the inception of
hainan man on on comedy bang bang so I
wonder if hang on man is going to keep
on spreading keep on getting perpetuated
you never know if it could be there
frostbite balls or their PPO if it's a
DLC relates you or their Frank esto
Frank as tubs Frank as tubs gains are
like stars there's another one born
every day yeah another would Craig so
kind of supermassive black hole yes and
just sort of imploding on itself quantum
mechanics or no astrophysics Astro ass
is dead gasps physics stank-ass physics
the dollar oh yeah well his boys dude
you to do well we talked merville and
and movies and TV Eric jonrosh yeah we
talked some miscellany you know some
entertainment then we got median greedy
and eloni an eloni baloney I really do
love a little like I really I'll take
comes through like it's alone loves us
too clearly yeah I want to hug us with
all of their aren't ya oh man and I'm
sure this won't be the last you've heard
of us on the subject yeah because if we
hopefully we're going to we're going to
do what it takes to get in to see all
four indices and well
we'll report back hell yeah hell yeah so
uh yeah yeah all right well that's our
show for tonight we're gonna go lock the
doors make sure no one from I'm going to
get a gun and just stay up all night I
mean a fear of toasts 50 days I don't
think you need to get a gun just load up
on Guernsey aware load off my guns bring
your friends it's fun to play and to
pretend yeah so overboard self-assured I
know I know I know a dirty word this has
been Nirvana spoken word our here on
dank your honor another tank radio dick
video this is the wife is so quiet with
dank tom this is kris jenkins shire mmm
and we was down malinka with these are
these are these are our indoor voices
yeah I don't know where the microphone
is on this computer Butler it's a lily
toss if you're at the top near the no
webcam what is it really you would have
to be why I'm pretty sure well now we're
doing voices and now we're not just
smoothing our voice we're doing our
voice yeah this has to stop before we
become somebody else entirely I would I
would eventually become what like I
think of Michael Silverblatt from
bookworm mm-hmm hey listen now I have
about summer okay it's on it's on NPR um
I'm the LAN Villar and Michael silver
bot has got an interesting kind of
cartoon man voice okay okay I'll go
check him up yeah his entomology podcast
does he have one i was i was making
everyone would obviously be a
literature-based show it is i don't know
it just got booked in the title bookworm
is a popular colloquialism for someone
who's like wicked into books all the
time so i thought it best room it sounds
like you're making this know what you
know what don't you don't you contradict
front of the viewers in front of the
listeners besides the listeners don't
you I will not I've never even done that
I've never contradicted you before what
are you talking
well I guess you're right yeah yeah
that's okay I flew off the handle there
I'm so so so yeah I know I just thought
it would be funny to go if you're about
if it was bad in sex instead of books
yeah his warm so booked my god like that
that segment that buck Henry I would do
on on the daily show the Henry stops
here because he knows like his name is
buck so you're totally expecting it but
no or like when they that joke with a
the gay radar it's a radar that measures
how gay you are we call it a homo meter
luggage is that that looks really
obvious silly reversal yeah so anyway I
just love that chance me the cell phone
tells me it's my dad Dan to say my dad
this is the cell phone I just that one
people I'm not a part of your system I
was one will be like bypassed the
immediate thing that you're thinking up
and go for the the other bit yeah it's a
lot of comedy miles yeah it's simple and
it's obvious but for me it works yeah
yeah I mean let you know there's a lot
of mileage eating and I've taking things
way too seriously with me yeah like I've
been on such a lonely island binge
lately and and a good portion of their
humor comes from like either reversing
concepts or just being way too into new
a boat or your dick not working yeah or
or just be like through another ground
is so funny to me just partly because he
just keeps on insisting that he's an
adult and he's not a part of your system
and it's like your dad called there's no
system here like it's you know it's I
just tickles me so mmm it's like dudes
who take [ __ ] way too serious I mean
honestly you know what this I mean it's
like that old classic line is you know
what the secret to cavity is threes no
oh ask me what's the secret to comedy
what's the secret to comedy subverting
expectation oh [ __ ] cuz I thought you
were gonna say timing what is that or
poop secret ticket counties it's always
prove how much mileage have we gotten
that of
r if it's with you I feel weird because
it's like you know the jank father the
Chang father what you know these podcast
this was an interesting hodgepodge good
because either side of the Pope
resection of Jeopardy I feel like these
are so varied because it's like it's
like the topic in and of itself is one
thing and then all the other extraneous
things don't quite go along with its own
so it's always got to be like a weird
four-course meal you know it's like
tomato soup blueberry pie an entire
roast pig yeah and just broccoli with
shredded parmesan yeah in a chocolate
fountain fountain yeah exactly it's like
this is a little bit everything I don't
know what that feels like but I guess
yeah a million great tastes that taste
weird together dig estos that's that's
the slope in the show yeah a million
great tastes that taste weird together
to guess tubs so thank you for joining
us Frank you thank you for being alone
with us for being alone with us once
again I'm Erin I am Sharon and remember
and we're airy and remember kids stay
alone stay alone forever alone p 1 just
lock yourself in your room and never
come out be in a closet yeah not the
club to say just be you know good i have
a closet in a closet yeah just call all
your friends and family into the nearest
closet and come out of the closet to
them whilst being in a physical closet
lock yourself with your clothes and let
them know that you get what was it a
closet I'm just curious I don't know I
don't know why the closet is where you
would put your you're being anything I
mean well you could come out from under
the bed like people have people sweep
things under there yeah or we might
under a rug there was some kind of like
maybe you have to do with skeletons in
the closet maybe people thought OD
happiness next to your skeleton I don't
know maybe some there was like some in I
kill this guy and also I'm gay I want to
put this here so that no one knows about
either I work at a science lab
and I stole a skeleton from the lab and
also I'm gay so I'm going to just put it
all my secrets in the same in the same
space we have to stop before these any
of these tangents get any further yeah
all right kids you dink and stay near
closet you go to your room go to your
room go home and and can give a look
into it give serious talk just give a
look to alone because they're they're
awesome vehicle very creative and even
if you can't go just just look them up
on it isn't just get metro traffic and
tell anyone you know in the LA area to
go be alone alone experience and unweave
the dank Bo unweave the dank bell